[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui à marcq échanges
et auteur d'un livre l'homme qui en
savait beaucoup trop aux éditions massot
il va nous révéler les dessous d'un
énorme scandale politico financier
impliquant areva ura mines il a
découvert alors qu'il était contractant
pour les services secrets chargés
d'enquêter sur le blanchiment d'argent
la corruption
alors bonjour marc échanges et merci
d'avoir répondu à votre invitation alors
si on peut vous parler aujourd'hui c'est
parce que vous avez été attaqué en
diffamation par anne lauvergeon qui
était président du directoire d'areva a
attaqué en diffamation alors vous avez
gagné il faut le dire mais en tout cas
vous êtes un peu grillé si je puis dire
pour continuer votre profession auprès
des services secrets
voilà en fait quand la sphère uram il a
éclaté en fin 2011 début 2012
elle a cru bon de faire des conférences
de presse et de m'attaquer en justice
pour un rapport que j'avais fait à
l'amiral d'arbonneau qui est kim avait
mandaté pour faire ce rapport aux
d'études sur l'acquisition de la société
ura mines et l'amiral d'arbonneau c'est
l'ancien patron de la force nucléaire
française
quelqu'un qui est qui était remarquable
qui est décédé aujourd'hui et l'amiral
me disait écoutez on a payé un milliard
huit d'euros pour acheter la société ura
mines et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
donc quand vous avez quelqu'un de ce
calibre qui vous dit je ne comprends pas
c'est qu'il ya vraiment un gros problème
est assez rapidement je me suis rendu
compte que cette société ura mines
étaient été largement officiers qui
avaient des problèmes lourds
vous aviez un des fondateurs qui était
sous mandat d'arrêt et personne n'a
vérifié tout ça que ce soit les banques
qui a présenté l'opération aussi bien
que le contrôle interne au niveau
d'areva donc il y avait un gros problème
sans parler des gisements d'uranium qui
était assez grotesque puisqu'il a
utilisé des côtés très longtemps oui
alors donc mais il était connu de la
france depuis très longtemps puisqu'il
nous appartenait avant j'ai ben si on
s'est adressé à vous justement thierry
d'arbonneau dont qui s'est adressé à
vous c'est parce que vous étiez très au
fait des questions financières pour
avoir été un ancien directeur de salle
de marché parce que c'était dans une
autre vie
lorsque vous étiez traders et puis
ensuite par de fil en aiguille de votre
vie de baroudeur vous en êtes arrivé à
faire des contrats avec les services
secrets pour justement enquêter sur
rollin délinquance financière comment ça
s'est passé exactement et en fait si
vous voulez une première partie de vie
dans laquelle je suis effectivement
traders et traders relativement connue
sur la petite place qu'est paris parce
que j'ai publié plusieurs ouvrages
financier parce que je publiais dans la
presse parce que j'avais aussi une
grosse puissance de feu sur la place
financière parisienne en tant que trader
et patron de salle des marchés et donc
été relativement connus j'ai fait aussi
à peu près une douzaine d'introductions
en bourse et le très peu de gens qui
peuvent avoir ce niveau là et qu'ils
peuvent aussi aller sur une zone de
guerre et voir ce qui se passe sur une
zone de guerre voir comment
certains groupuscules se financent donc
je suis allé en irak à partir de fin
2005 et j'y suis resté jusqu'à la
signature du sofa wheelman le départ des
troupes américaines
j'y suis revenu un peu après oui
d'ailleurs si on parle de l'irak vous
avez assisté vous étiez là aussi pour
enquêter sur le détournement des fonds
des deux américains pour la
reconstruction de l'irak
eh bien figurez-vous que oui après après
l'opération iraqi freedom qui a duré à
peu près six mois et george bush était
parfaitement en droit d'annoncer qu'il y
avait une victoire quand il a quand il
était sur son porte-avions et qu'il a
dit on a gagné la guerre il avait raison
le problème qui s'est passé c'est que
après il ya eu la période de
reconstruction et il ya eu un énorme
transfert de la fed le plus gros
transfert de cash que la fed ait jamais
faite dans son histoire en faveur de
l'irak
et donc j'ai vu des sacs remplis de
billets est rejetée des hélicoptères est
distribué par les marines un peu partout
et l'idée c'était on va reconstruire on
va on va on va tellement injecter de
cash dans la société qu'on va pouvoir
reconstruire rapidement et on va gagner
le comme toujours le coeur et les
esprits par cette reconstruction sans
avoir en fait la connaissance du tissu
économique et mafieux aussi que qui
avait en irak et donc ces fonds ont été
détournés en très grande majorité
j'en ai vu partir pour la petite
histoire lors des cercueils traverser la
la frontière turque
c'était récupéré par une banque suisse à
istanbul est çà çà çà çà allaient à
genève et donc ce petit manège là vous
l'imaginez multiplier largement et ça
donne un gros désastre qui fait que en
fait la reconstruction américaine a
échoué
ce que je regrette parce que ça a été un
drame un drame humain beaucoup de
souffrance pour tout le monde et ça
aurait été beaucoup mieux s'il avait
réussi et malheureusement de voiliers
l'invasion a eu lieu en 2003 2004
on est en 2020 on peut pas dire que le
monde soit meilleur après après cette
invasion
et si les meilleurs je dirais il est pas
meilleure pour les américains il est pas
meilleure pour les russes il est pas
meilleure pour l'europe et je vois pas
où comment en quoi il serait meilleur au
moyen-orient donc vous voyez c'est ça
reste un drame humain très très lourd et
donc suite à ça j'ai été dans différents
pays africains dans le nord kivu une
grande expérience en afrique et ensuite
en 2010 comme vous le disiez vous êtes
chargé par le directeur de la sécurité
du groupe areva d'enquêter sur cet achat
1,8 milliard d'euros 2,5 milliards de
dollars 2 min inexploitables et vous
après une enquête assez sommaire ce que
vous dites que le contrat n'était pas
suffisamment élevé pour que vous fassiez
des grandes investigations en tout cas
vous trouvez tout de suite que ça peut
être un délit d'initié
l'argent a jamais été tellement mon
moteur mais effectivement j'avais un
contrat de vingt mille euros qui
permettait pas de faire grand chose
et puis on s'attendait pas à trouver
quelque chose d'aussi énorme quels
éléments tout de suite vous ont conduit
à penser que c'est un délit d'initié le
peu de consistance qu'il y avait dans ce
document dopé à qui avait dans la
réalité des licences minière et je me
suis dit tout de suite là on vient de
perdre un milliard huit il restera rien
de cet achat c'est une escroquerie c'est
ce que j'ai dit à la presse
et quand je disais escroquerie à
l'époque j'avais pas tous les détails
mais aujourd'hui j'en ai beaucoup plus
est en fait oui cet argent a été
entièrement perdue provisionné ça crée
sa emmené areva
à la faillite par la suite il a fallu
recapitaliser changer le nom etc
mais voilà ça fait partie du plus grand
drame d'arrêt bas ça dévoile fruits non
c'est non on en parlera tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs mais comment se présenter
cette opération puisse y avait donc deux
hommes qui avaient une société
canadienne pour vendre les trois mines
vous pouvez nous nous situer le contexte
absolument le contexte il est il et il
est assez croustillant vous avez d'un
côté quelqu'un qui s'appelle steven date
elle ce que je pense ce lié aux services
américains est sans doute avec une
double nationalité canadienne et
américaine qui fonde une société minière
avec james mullen que l'on retrouve dans
le financement du breakbeat d'ailleurs
et il achète des licences minières pour
quelques milliers de dollars vraiment
très peu de choses donc ça se passe en
namibie en centrafrique et on afrique du
sud et james date l on le connaît déjà
parce qu'il a fait un deal avec eramet
et ça s'appelle weda bay et alors il
ramène à l'époque était détenu par 20 %
d'areva
mais il y avait beaucoup de il y avait
beaucoup de bébés du personnel qui
travaillait à la fois la tête d' eramet
et à la tête d'areva
donc il y avait des maisons des intérêts
croisés et weda bay ça a été un four
complet évidemment là aussi
l'acquisition de weda bay par eramet ya
de quoi écrire un livre
donc on connaissait absolument
absolument james mellon on le
connaissait aussi et dans l'huile a un
parcours un peu différent mais ce fait
est que dans son parcours il se retrouve
impliqué dans une fraude et il est le la
corée du sud est mais un mandat d'arrêt
à son encontre
le mandat d'arrêt parfaitement valides
au moment où il fait l'opération jura
mine avec son ami stéphane dath health
alors comment on n'est pas très courant
mais oui merci ça mais comment on peut
expliquer qu'une c'est un groupe énorme
comme areva qui est spécial
et puissent acheter des mines
inexploitables à au moins un escroc sur
les deux fondateurs de la société
voilà alors en fait ça n'est pas
explicable le fait est que on voit tout
de suite quand on démonte la faire que
par exemple les réserves ont été
certifiés par des géologues qui avait
créé une société qui à l'origine
appartenait la cogema on voit que c'est
mine cédant centrafrique était connu de
la cogema tout toupet vous avez en
namibie l'origine de la licence la
licence minière elle appartenait un des
héritiers d'elvis presley au ca c'est
assez cocasse et on sait très bien quand
vous avez une licence minier on sait
très bien son historique
donc on n'avait aucune difficulté à
retracer disons le
son histoire et la qualité de ce que ça
pouvait avoir et à ce moment là quel
était l'intérêt d'anne lauvergeon
d'engager la société dans cet achat si
catastrophique mais l'idée de base et on
va parler avec on va parler de
corruption présumée puisque la sphère
n'a pas été jugé que le dossier toujours
ouvert l'idée de base dans ce genre
d'opération c'est de faire vous achetez
une société et vous entendez avec le peu
d'actionnaires qu'il ya derrière cette
société bien qu'elle soit coté à londres
et et au canada il y avait très peu de
d'actionnaires et il y avait très peu
d'activités sur cette société
donc vous achetez cette société très
cher comme si je vous achetez votre
voiture à un prix défiant toute
concurrence donc et derrière je
m'arrange pour récupérer les fonds
évidemment je vous laisse une commission
intéressante et ils ont touché plusieurs
je crois que de mémoire simdat tels
c'est de l'ordre de 60 millions $ et
derrière je récupère les fonds et donc
ces fonds ils vont servir à quoi ils
vont servir
c'est une petite d'une petite poche qui
va se permettre de
corrompre des gouvernements étrangers
afin de pouvoir vendre des op r c'est ça
l'idée de base qui entre guy qui est
toujours entre guillemets puisque
l'affairé toujours instruites donc il
faut être juridiquement prudent et c'est
votre hypothèse en tout cas votre
hypothèse de l'oreille c'est que cet
argent
donc c'est à jean quasiment indues pour
déminer inexploitables va servir à
alimenter des caisses noires qui vont
servir à de la population pour ce qu'on
a pu tracer parce que il ya eu des
victimes
c'est ce qui s'est passé en chine avec
la faire quand green green qui était le
patron du programme nucléaire chinois
il ya un moment areva et discuter avec
la chine de ventes de ppr et
suite à la signature d'un contrat quand
grighine est arrêté avec lui sont
arrêtés une cinquantaine de personnes
par la police chinoise et vous avez un
représentant d'areva qui m'ont dit ben
voila vous nous donnez votre pastore
vous restez sur place et c'est madame
lagarde qui a dû se déplacer pour
essayer de dison de sortir de cette
situation et il est avéré que la presse
a rapporté que les chinois avaient
touché 260 millions de dollars en tout
comment ça s'est réparti je ne sais pas
mais il ya eu à la fois des négociations
pour que la personne en question puisse
rentrer chez elle en france et il ya
aussi des négociations pour qui un
transfert de technologie vis-à-vis de la
chine entre la france et la chine dont
un au niveau des ep r et si vous
regardez ce qui se passe avec une clé
poynt aujourd'hui si les chinois
construisent inc les portes aujourd'hui
c'est grâce au transfert de technologie
de cette époque là merci marc étagères
on va marquer une courte pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
marc échanges et auteur du livre l'homme
qui en savait beaucoup trop aux éditions
massot sur l'énorme scandale politico
financier d'areva ura mine alors de
retour marqué échanges et anne
lauvergeon s'est démené pour acheter ces
mines il n'y a pas eu de garde-fous
finalement elle a réussi à passer outre
non il ya eu au grain aucun garde-fou
dans la mesure où 1
les géologues n'ont pas eu leur mot à
dire lagence de la participation de
l'état à une certaine complicité et les
commissaires aux comptes ont été
grassement rémunérés bien plus que de
normal quand on regarde la courbe des
factures des commissaires aux comptes on
voit que le pic a lieu en 2008 2009 et
que c'est très élevé et malheureusement
il ya eu aucun garde-fou qui a
fonctionné normalement vous avez une
société comme areva est là elle a le
droit à tous les services de l'état elle
a le droit à l'accès à la dgse à la dgsi
tout peut être vérifiée donc si la dgsi
que confirme que quelqu'un comme dance
mellon a un mandat d'arrêt le concernant
bah évidemment ça bloque l'opération
évidemment ça doit figurer dans le
prospectus dopé à et tout ça n'existe
pas dans le prospectus de pea il se
passe rien donc l'opération elle se fait
comme si de rien n'était et ça se
termine en drame puisque de ce milliard
il ne sortira jamais rien mais qu'est
devenu cet argent déjà parce que selon
vos informations il a dû aller quelques
bras alors l'argent l'argent on peut
dire qu'il ya eu trois potentiels source
de dison de 2,2 de sommes versées et
vous avez la chine avec l'acer quang
ninh où il ya eu 50 personnes d'arrêter
y compris quand easing qui était
responsable du programme nucléaire
chinois lui il a été condamné à la
prison à vie pour corruption
donc il y a encore en prison je pense
qu'il est toujours vivant et il ya eu
suite à cette affaire là un transfert de
technologie entre areva et la chine
madame lagarde s'est déplacé pour
résoudre la situation qui était très
conflictuelle vu que les chinois ne
voulait plus parler à madame lauvergeon
et donc laisser madame lagarde qui a
solutionné le problème il ya une
deuxième enveloppe on va dire qu'ils
étaient destinés au kazakhstan puisque
areva voulait des mines au kazakhstan et
là le responsable de gazprom et par
client aussi en prison le pauvre s'est
retrouvé dans un quartier de haute
sécurité est là pour lui ça a été
l'horreur c'est ou parle d'une cellule
où vous êtes complètement l isolement
on vous donne juste à manger donc c'est
comme si vous étiez en mur est vivant
aux dernières nouvelles il en est sorti
il ya peu de temps et il se retrouve
dans un camp de travail mais il serait
toujours vivant et puis il ya eu la
partie la partie enveloppe afrique du
sud qui était très importante puisqu'il
était question de vendre 12 p r ce qui
est un vrai délire à l'afrique du sud
quand vous savez qu'en afrique du sud il
ya qu'une vieille centrale qui a été
construite dans les années 70 et que
l'opérateur sud africain eskom et est en
faillite permanente
bon ben vous voyez bien dans quel état
il met bien très étrange de vouloir
vendre à des experts mais vous avez le
des jacob zuma jacob zuma qui a succédé
à thabo mbeki juste pendant la période
charnière qu'on concède qu'on
dont on parle qui lui a été inculpé de
mémoire 17 fois donc je sais pas où il
en est dans son procès mais bon c'est la
corruption est tellement importante en
afrique du sud qu'on peut même pas qu'on
se voie d'y construire un dpr quoi alors
justement ce qui est très étonnant c'est
que d'une part ya l'achat de ces mines
est inexploitable et pas seulement le
scandale ura mine parce qu'il y en a
d'autres en indonésie sont allés parler
au niger il ya aussi des construction de
deux usines de traitement de mox aux
états unis qui ne marche pas
construction de poésie le marché voilà
pourquoi un tel degré de la menthe et
russes pour un fleuron français
alors vous vous retrouvez dans une
situation où à vous avez un trou de 1
milliard huit il ya rien en face et on a
vendu aucun de pm et donc il va falloir
meublés et donc c'est à ce moment là que
vous avez imouraren qui sort comme ça du
chapeau imouraren c'est une mine que
l'on connaît parfaitement depuis les
années 70 j'ai retrouvé un document de
la cia qui mentionne imouraren et à
l'époque on avait parfaitement identifié
que ce n'était pas vraiment une mine
c'est un endroit où vous avez des
petites lentilles d'uranium dans le sol
mais pour faire une vraie mine si vous
voulez il faut il faut qu'il ya un vrai
si l'on que vous puissiez suivre
et donc là c'est parfaitement
inexploitables et 7 et humour à rennes a
été valorisé comptablement de mémoire 1
milliard 3 avant de valloire 0
aujourd'hui sa nacelle n'a jamais été
exploité évidemment ça ne le sera jamais
mais ça permet de facturer et d'envoyer
aussi des gratifications on va dire à
des à des politiciens nigérien tout ça
n'est pas perdu et puis vous aviez donc
les
la sphère américaine l'affairé sera qui
est peut-être la plus scandaleuse et en
tout cas celle qui a le plus d'impact
aujourd'hui puisque dans l'affairé ausra
areva par hachette voilà areva achète à
al gore une société s'appelle haussera
et qui est censé produire de l'énergie
solaire et cette société on va la payer
240 millions de dollars alors qu'elle
était à là jamais fait de bénéfices
qu'elle est dans un état au bord de la
faillite et vous retrouvez donc au
capital al gore vous retrouvez à une
partie de l'establishment démocrate
indirectement vous retrouver john kerry
qui est actionnaire d'un fonds qui lui
est actionnaire de haut sera vous
retrouvez un démocrate connu comme harry
reid qui fait la promotion ne sera pas
donc vous avez tout l'établissement
démocrate et est donc à areva va réussir
à avoir des contrats aux états unis et
puis aussi des gratifications un moment
moi j'ai un e-mail qui a été validé par
une cour américaine à qui mentionne que
pau tus et donc à l'époque peux tu sais
président d' inhumain des states
pontus c'est obama obama donne son
accord pour qu'areva bénéficie d'un prêt
de 2 milliards de dollars alors que
l'agent ce qui est censé gérer ces prêts
un avis négatif
il intervient personnellement dans le
dossier ce qui est pas le rôle du tout
d'un président des états unis pour que
areva touche ces deux milliards de prêts
c'est à dire ce qu'est la gestion
fantaisiste d'arrêt d'areva a des
répercussions incroyable jusqu'au
président américain
absolument absolument et salaf héros
sera si si vous souhaitez en faire un
documentaire un jour moi j'ai toutes les
vidéos toutes les pièces absolument tous
les détails parce que vous imaginez bien
que comme ça voilà quand vous dites des
choses comme ça qui implique al gore
vous faites pas ça à la légère
toutes ces pièces ont été données à la
mrc c'est la nuclear regulatory
commission aux états unis à la mrc
montaleau mon interlocuteur c'est un
signe en spéciale et john ancien de ice
dont le prénom ses marques et je vais
pas donner son nom de famille
c'est ça ne se fait pas
mais tout croyez moi tout a été donnée
de même que tout a été donné au web bay
en ce qui concerne duras mines et donc
qu'ils sont parfaitement au courant de
ça et peut-être que si al gore et pas
président est pas aujourd'hui dans la
course à la présidentielle
cc c'est un très certainement dit voilà
c'est très facile car les répercussions
judiciaires de tout cela parce que deux
instructions étaient ouvertes à
concernant areva anne lauvergeon alors
une pour escroquerie et abus de biens
sociaux corruption d'agent public
étranger et une seconde pour diffusion
de fausses informations au marché
présentation de comptes inexacts abus de
pouvoir faux et usage de faux on en est
ou au point de vue de la justice alors
de ce que je sais elle a été mise en
examen trois fois et elle est témoin
assisté dans la partie escroquerie
corruption donc de le volet français on
va dire il suit son cours je ne sais pas
quand ça sera jugé ça suit son cours le
volet américain puisque moi j'ai
transmis le dossier concernant la
corruption et le de ce dossier là est
éligible à la loi américaine anti
corruption
donc j'ai tout transmis à la ici iolite
hannachi cox unit du fbi y aille je ne
sais pas où ça en est parce que le fbi
ne commente pas ces procédures mais je
pense que si la france conclut un jour
qui s'est rien passé à ce niveau là ils
appuieront sur le bouton cette cession
est catastrophique ces histoires de
corruption présumée par vous et par
d'autres d'ailleurs ont une répercussion
notamment sur le contribuable français
quelles sont elles
énorme énorme puisque pour vous donner
une idée quand areva a été construite à
peu près il y avait soixante quatorze
mille employés en 2010 on a quarante
cinq mille camp et puis évidemment ça
s'effondre jusqu'à 20000 cc quasiment
dérisoire aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
devenu orane aux orane eux on se demande
déjà comment l'art capitaliser la
recapitalisation qui a eu l ai déjà
partis en fumée
c'est c'est une énorme perte la cour des
comptes a fait un dossier qui est paru
le 9 juillet 2020 catastrophique surtout
ce qui est filière prl la filière
nucléaire française
donc on va dire qu'elle a été tellement
dommage et que moi je pense que il y a
peu d'espoir il ya ça sera difficile de
reconstituer un fleuron français comme
celle l'était je pense pas ça soit
souhaitable mais il faut maintenir un
certain niveau de connaissance parce que
ben des réacteurs on en a en france
il va falloir à un moment ou un autre
les démanteler
il va falloir pallier à cette absence de
production électrique au moment où edf à
60 milliards de dettes dans son bilan la
capitalisation boursière d'edf c'est
quelque chose comme 25 milliards d'euros
c'est quasiment un à flamanville ennemis
j'allais lire tellement seul oeil cette
p r est un gouffre et je souhaite pour
les français que l' agence de sûreté
française fasse son travail jusqu'au
bout nous sécurise un maximum et ne
tiennent pas compte des pressions
politiques ou financières parce qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'eux une sécurité
maximum
et vous voyez moi je ne suis pas pour ou
contre le nucléaire
je suis simplement pour une industrie
sans corruption parce que cette
industrie là si elle crée un incident et
vous le savez très bien avec tchernobyl
si elle crée un incident
c'est pour l'éternité donc c'est pas
c'est pas juste pour nous c'est pour nos
enfants nos petits-enfants et et au delà
donc c'est très important que on arrive
à conserver et à redonner à une
industrie nucléaire mondial qui soit
propre sans corruption et qu'on puisse
balayer les dossiers en cours et c'est
pour ça que j'encourage à nos amis des
services russes à m'envoyer tout ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir
parce que ça sera le seul moyen au
niveau international on puisse
reconsidérer qu'on peut effectivement
construire des centrales
sans trop de risques je vous rappelle
aussi qu aux etats unis l affaire du mox
le moc c'était une usine qui a été
construite
enfin construite on a dépensé plus de 10
milliards de dollars dans cette
infrastructure en pure perte et le but
du jeu c'était de pouvoir modifier de
l'uranium militaire en uranium civile le
pouvoir transformer cet uranium unités
en uranium si lille à un moment donc la
dîmière poutine peu donne son feu vert
pour que cet uranium militaires puissent
être traitées aux états unis et puis il
s'est déjà quasiment au départ que ça
n'ira nulle part puisque c'est areva qui
est en train de monter cette usine il
sait parfaitement ce qui se passe et il
sait que c'est ça n'ira nulle part
je vous remercie beaucoup marqué chargé
de nous avoir parlé de toute cette
affaire très scandaleux dans le scandale
républicain d'areva avec ura mines
je rappelle le titre de votre livre qui
est l'homme à qui on savait beaucoup
trop aux éditions massot pourrait revoir
cette émission sur rtl france point tva
bientôt sur rt france merci beaucoup
[Musique]
i